BUT FIRST, STAR OF THE VIRUS,
NOT THE ECONOMY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
BY NOW WE HAVE ALL BECOME PRETTY
EFFICIENT AT AVOIDING DUMB
THINGS LIKE HUGGING PEOPLE,
SHAKING HANDS, NONESSENTIAL
TRAVEL, 6 FEET APART, WASHING
OUR HANDS, DON’T TOUCH THE GAS
HANDLE, NO FACE TOUCHING, WIPING
KNOBS BEFORE YOU TOUCH THEM,
FRANKLY NOT EVEN TOUCHING KNOBS
AT ALL.
>> OUR COUNTRY HAS LEARNED A
LOT, LEARNED ABOUT SOCIAL
DISTANCING, LEARNED ABOUT THE
HANDS, STAYING AWAKE DURING THE
TIME THE THIS IS EVEN A LITTLE B
AROUND, THIS DISEASE OR WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
>> LIFE IN AMERICA IS ON PAUSE
IN AN ATTEMPT TO STOP THIS
VIRUS.
WE HAVE MORE THAN 80 MILLION
AMERICANS ALIVE, WHO ARE STAYING
HOME DUE TO STATE ORDERS.
THAT IS UNDOUBTEDLY SLOWING THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS, WHICH IS A
VERY GOOD THING.
MORE THAN 550 AMERICANS HAVE NOW
SUCCUMBED TO COVID-19, WE DON’T
HAVE A BREAKDOWN YET OF MEDIAN
AGE OR WHETHER THEY HAD
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS BUT WE
WILL AT SOME POINT.
OF COURSE, WE ON "THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE" KNOW EVERY LIFE LOST IS A
TRAGEDY, EVERY LIFE LOST IS
IRREPLACEABLE.
BUT WE ARE TESTING A LOT MORE
PEOPLE, THAT’S A REALLY GOOD
THING.
WE ARE FINDING THAT MORE
AMERICANS ARE INFECTED, AS THE
PRESIDENT NOTED TONIGHT, WE ARE
GATHERING NEW DATA ON MORTALITY
RATES AS WELL.
>> THE MORTALITY RATES, I THINK
WE ARE VERY SUBSTANTIAL IN THE
1%.
IT IS STILL TERRIBLE, THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF DEATH IS TERRIBLE.
BUT DOES A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOMETHING LIKE 1%
AND 4 OR 5 OR EVEN 3%.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE ARE
LEARNING NOW, I THINK THE NUMBER
MAY BE LOWER.
>> SEVEN DAYS MORE TO GO OF OUR
NATIONAL TIMEOUT, THE PRESIDENT
WITH A MULTIFACTOR ANALYSIS
RIGHTLY RAISED THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF A PROLONGED
SHUTDOWN.
>> YOU CAN’T KEEP IT CLOSED FOR
THE NEXT YEARS, THIS IS GOING
AWAY.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN THE BATTLE,
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE HAVE JOBS, PEOPLE GET
TREMENDOUS ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION AND YOU HAVE SUICIDES
OVER THINGS LIKE THIS WHEN YOU
HAVE TERRIBLE ECONOMIES, YOU
HAVE DEATH, PROBABLY IN FAR
GREATER NUMBERS THAT THE NUMBERS
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WITH
REGARDS TO THE VIRUS.
>> Laura: WE ALL KNOW THAT
ALONG WITH THE HUMAN DEATH TOLL
OF THE VIRUS, AS THE PRESIDENT
DISCUSSED THE ECONOMIC CARNAGE
IS MOUNTING.
ONE OF MY OLD FRIENDS FROM
EL SALVADOR CALLED ME TODAY AND
SHE WAS CRYING.
HER HUSBAND LOST HIS PLUMBING
JOB TODAY.
HER SISTER LOST HER MARKETING
JOB ON FRIDAY.
>> WE ARE GOING TO SAVE AMERICAN
WORKERS.
AND WE ARE GOING TO SAVE THEM
QUICKLY.
AND WE ARE GOING TO SAVE OUR
GREAT AMERICAN COMPANIES, BOTH
SMALL AND LARGE.
THIS WAS A MEDICAL PROBLEM, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO LET IT TURN
INTO A LONG-LASTING FINANCIAL
PROBLEM.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, SOME OF
THE PRESS BEING THE SIMPLETONS
THEY ARE, THEY WANT TO MAKE THIS
A STRUGGLE BETWEEN DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI OF THE CDC AND THE
PRESIDENT.
>> IF WE GET TO NEXT WEEK, YOU
ARE DECIDING WHAT TO DO WITH
THESE GUIDELINES WHETHER TO EASE
THEM OR INSTITUTE THEM FOR
ANOTHER 15 DAYS, WILL YOU FOLLOW
THE ADVICE OF DR. FAUCI IF THEY
SAY YOU SHOULD MAINTAIN THEM?
>> WE WILL HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION, I CERTAINLY LISTEN TO
THEM AND A NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
DR. FAUCI, DR. DEBORAH BIRX.
I WILL BE LISTENING TO THEM AND
OTHERS THAT ARE DOING A REALLY
GOOD JOB.
>> Laura: IN THE END, IT IS
THE PRESIDENT WHO IS THE ONE
TASKED WITH MAKING THE TOUGH
CALLS, THAT IS WHY HE WAS
ELECTED.
IN PEACETIME AND WAR TIME, HE
HAS THE SAME RESPONSIBILITY.
HE GETS A LOT OF INPUT, HE
CONVENES A LOT OF MEETINGS WITH
A LOT OF SMART PEOPLE AND HE
LOOKS AT THE DATA AND
PROJECTIONS, BUT THE FINAL
DECISION ALWAYS RESTS WITH HIM.
NOW, WE ALL KNOW THAT IN LIFE
THERE ARE INHERENT RISKS.
WE LIVE WITH THOSE EVERY DAY
WHEN WE STEP INTO OUR CARS,
FRANKLY JUST WALK OUT THE FRONT
DOOR.
IT IS ALWAYS A BALANCING ACT,
AND LIFE AND IN POLITICS BETWEEN
FREEDOM AND SECURITY.
LIBERTY AND SAFETY.
THE PRESIDENT IS NEVER GOING TO
PLEASE EVERYBODY, NEVER.
BUT AMERICA AT SOME POINT SOON,
HE SAID, WEEKS, NOT MONTHS, WILL
HAVE TO FUNCTION AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO BE A COUNTRY TOGETHER
AGAIN.
AND A SAFE.
AT TIMES LIKE THIS, WE NEED
MORE, NOT LESS INPUT FROM REALLY
SMART PEOPLE.
AND AT TIMES LIKE THIS, THINK OF
PREIRAQ WAR.
IT IS DIFFICULT TO BE THE ONE
QUESTIONING THE CONSENSUS,
PHENOMENAL SCHOLARS LIKE JOHN
UNITAS OR DAVID KATZ, THEY ARE
TAKING A BEATING FOR EVEN
SUGGESTING THAT WE MAY NEED TO
RECONSIDER SOME OF OUR INITIAL
THINKING ABOUT THIS VIRUS AND
OUR RESPONSE TO IT.
THEY SHOULD BE HEARD, ALONG WITH
EVERYONE ELSE, WITHOUT
CENSORSHIP.
THE WIDELY RESPECTED
SILICON VALLEY FORECASTER AARON
GIVEN HAS A PERSUASIVE AND WELL
ARGUED PIECE ON HOPE AND
OPTIMISM ON THE VIRUS REMOVED
FROM THE INTERNET, IT WAS
REPOSTED ELSEWHERE.
HE IS BEING SMEARED RIGHT NOW BY
ACADEMICS.
THIS IS WRONG.
AND REVEALING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN A RECENT
POLLING, IF THIS IS ACCURATE,
THEY CAME TO APPRECIATE THE WAY
THE PRESIDENT HAS HANDLED THIS
CRISIS.
DAY AFTER DAY, HE STOOD BEFORE
THE PRESS CORPS ANSWERING
QUESTIONS FOUR HOURS.
HIS LOVE AND RESPECT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, FOR OUR
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS, AND
OUR BUSINESSES, OUR WORKERS IS
EVIDENT, SHINES THROUGH.
HE DOESN’T WANT OUR SOLUTION TO
THIS CRISIS TO END UP BEING
WORSE THAN THE INSIDIOUS VIRUS
ITSELF.
THAT MEANS EVERYONE HAS TO WORK
TOGETHER.
EVERYONE HAS TO DO HIS OR HER
PART.
>> I WILL WORK WITH ANYONE TO
HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, I
WILL.
I DON’T CARE WHO IT IS, I WILL
WORK WITH ANYBODY.
IF I FEEL I AM GOING TO HELP THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE AMERICAN
WORKER.
>> Laura: IT CAN THE DEMOCRATS
WHO HAVE HELD UP THIS LATEST
RELIEF/STIMULUS BILL FOR THE
LAST TWO DAYS, CAN THEY SAY THE
SAME?
SCHUMER AND PELOSI HAS BEEN
DISGUSTING, WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
TO AMERICAN FAMILIES AND
AMERICAN WORKERS.
THEY ARE HOLDING THE COUNTRY
HOSTAGE, TRYING TO EXTRACT
POLICY CONCESSIONS LIKE WIND AND
SOLAR SUBSIDIES, MAIL IN
BALLOTS, EARLY VOTING FOR FALL,
NOTHING TO DO, ZERO TO DO WITH
COVID-19.
>> WE HAD A DEAL, I WAS PRETTY
SURE HOW TO DEAL LAST NIGHT.
AT A CERTAIN TIME, ABOUT 9:00 I
WOULD HAVE TOLD YOU WE PRETTY
MUCH HAVE A DEAL.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, IT
CHANGED, IT CHANGED FAIRLY
RAPIDLY.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN BAD FOR OUR
COUNTRY, THEY WERE ASKING FOR
THINGS THAT WOULD HAVE NOT
BEEN -- THINGS THAT BORE NO
RELATIONSHIP TO WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE CAN’T PLAY THAT GAME.
>> Laura: NO, WE CAN’T.
THIS ISN’T A GAME.
THIS IS A COUNTRY, AND WE ARE
TRYING TO SAVE PEOPLE, THEIR
LIVES, AND ANY PROCESS OUR
FREEDOM, OUR CONSTITUTION.
WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE HARD
DECISIONS WITH THE BEST
INFORMATION WE CURRENTLY HAVE,
REAL DATA.
AGAIN, BALANCING FREEDOM AND
SECURITY, LIBERTY, SAFETY.
AT THE END OF IT ALL, WE STILL
WANT A COUNTRY THAT HAS A STRONG
CHANCE OF BEING PROSPEROUS AND
HAPPY AGAIN.